where did your sense of style come I
think because I got with a mother that
could so she would make all my clothes
for me ever since I was little yeah so I
was able to think things up and tear
things out of magazines when I got to be
a teenager and she would make them for
my sister and I
so our prom dresses my mom made yeah
that was her that's awesome yeah so I
think that's probably why I love clothes
so much because I would watch them and I
also really loved Couture because in
that because I know what it takes to
make things and I've the mastery in a
Couture dress is just like takes my
breath away to have your mom make your
clothes when you're little you would
never think oh my gosh I'm gonna be then
having Tom Ford or Karl Lagerfeld or
John Galliano or you know Sarah Burton
who make a dress for me how does your
husband let you come out looking like
this and walk by yourself Jimmy Kimmel
tonight he's racing here so I I said
don't leave me on the cava that would be
weird
come straight to the table we know his
birthday is Wednesday since he's not
here we can talk are there any big plans
small plans because we're such a close
family he said I want nothing big I just
want the the four of us together but
we've organized things we've got stuff
you've got a girls and I have planned it
he doesn't know exactly who I
I think when you're just a really close
family the last thing I want to do is go
out and have some big party you just he
just wants to be surrounded by his girls
so that's what he's getting